thanks for being with us for the news
here noon everyone i'm alex backus we do
begin in florida here at noon
where crews are still searching for
survivors after a building collapsed
overnight in surf site it is quite the
scene
we now know nearly 100 people are
missing at least one person has died
manuela jorquez is in surf side with the
effort to find survivors
i'm thankful that i survived this it's
hard to fathom
just after 2 a.m this 12-floor condo
building and surf side suddenly crashing
to the ground
i was in a deep sleep and all of a
sudden i hear a
huge huge crash of
thunder that i thought it was just north
of miami beach this idyllic neighborhood
is now
a disaster zone the tv doesn't do it
justice i mean it is
really really a traumatic to see
the problem is the building has
literally pancaked
there's just feet in between stories
where there were
10 feet that is
is heartbreaking mayor charles burkett
fears finding survivors alive may be
unlikely
as daylight renews the search and rescue
effort that began overnight
and earlier crews were seen recovering a
young boy from the rubble
he was just really panicked he said that
his mom was in there with him
his arm was pinned like i said it was
sheer panic
what caused the deadly accident is still
unclear we're all just
scratching our heads trying to imagine
what in the world could have happened
many of these beachside condos are owned
by retirees who
leave for the summer but the mayor of
the town of suicide confirmed to us
that families were living here full time
manuel bejorquez
cbs news surfside florida
it is just terrible again 100 people
missing right now we will follow all
those developments today from surfside
bringing you all those updates here on
air also on our website that's 8 news
now.com